my biggest problem with democrats
call it considering myself one of them
and
this trickles then into media narratives
is that democrats judge policies
based on their intentions rather than
their results
and then if you criticize the results
they treat you like you are a critic of
the intention
if you criticize some of the specific
results coming out of these curriculums
or saying that
i don't think this is even actually
going to help fight systemic racism they
will tell you
you don't believe systemic racism exists
and that is
so frustrating um so we have to be able
to have a conversation that both
acknowledges stomach racism
and has a healthy debate about the the
specifics in certain curriculums
and that is the point that is why we
have two peop two white people talking
about race right now because we
have to talk about it you know if you
don't talk about this it just bottles up
and it's shitty
and i felt you feel it all the time
don't talk about this you just get
people
who get so ingrained in their own
narrative that they don't realize
that the other side is fighting
something completely different you're
like you're not even you're
you're not arguing on the same plane
we're not arguing about the same things
we're having totally different
[Music]
conversations
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks your special
thursday episodes this is your thursday
update so here's what we're gonna do
um i told you guys we're working on some
things for the fall
over the summer i'm gonna try some we're
gonna try something new on thursdays i
think you all are going to like um
talk about having carly on but we
haven't really identified what we're
going to do so what we're going to do
is we're going to target like a tight 30
minute update
on essentially narratives
in our mainstream media right now
frankly
what narratives are being covered and
when they are wrong what's not getting
through there's so many times where the
right says one thing
the left is saying another and i think
unless you're a rabid fan of either
those sides you're kind of stuck in like
where the hell do i go
for news um and carly we've lived this
personally and professionally on the
yang campaign and also in the mayor's
race at least from
just knowing and being close with the
yang's um
we've seen how the media does this
ourselves and i think we have a unique
voice here
and can help you all so both for the
world and for our audience we are
excited about this
and carly and i'm going to break this
down for you try to shoot for 30 minutes
if we go over
we'll figure it out but um it's not a
harsh timeline but we want to keep it
tight for you guys you know
we know you're busy anyway carly riley
welcome back how we doing
doing well doing well i'm really excited
about this i think uh
there are a few who are more frustrated
by media narratives than you and me
this is true and uh excited that we're
gonna take them on
well what's fun is also um we were
debating what we wanted to start with
and we're gonna start off with a bang
um just go right in um because today's
topic
i wanted to start we both wanted to
start with something that everybody's
talking about
everyone has some form of opinion and
something that's polarizing so we're
going to talk about today
critical race theory um so i'm gonna set
this up and i'm gonna i'm gonna turn it
to carly to kind of break this down for
us but here's
what seems to be happening critical race
theory is all over the news both
msnbc box the left read me the right
media they're all covering it
and the narratives that are coming out
are not fun
or easy to digest essentially and this
is going to be the layman's version
we're going to dive in but the right
seems to be saying that critical race
theory is anti-american
and destroying america um
and the left is saying that critical
race theory is essential
and that those who don't understand it
or don't want to talk about it
are unable to see the systemic
racism in this country um and it's a
very divisive
topic i actually push back on that i
think that the the narrative on the left
is that
we're not even critical race theory is
not actually what we're talking about
here and that the right is wrong to be
calling things critical race theory
either way i feel like if you're the
right you hate it and if you're left
you're not allowed to criticize it
because if you do you're you feel like
you're a racist or doing something
um against what um
democrats are supposed to be fighting
for let's say and i think as usual the
truth is somewhere in the middle and one
of the things and i'll say this kind of
the first episode but
as we do this i don't want you to come
to us all the time for just like our
opinions what i want to do is kind of a
breakdown of the news and what
um you guys are adults make your own
decisions and based on um
the facts coming out of these narratives
or that are being ignored by these
narratives so
um so carly can you
help us understand maybe like basic
maybe start us with like
the high level definition of critical
race theory and then where these
narratives are kind of going
left right and sideways sure um i
actually think
and i will all kind of loosely define it
but i think that
the narrative that i see missing right
now in this conversation honestly or the
points that i see not being made
um is actually that the definition of
critical race theory is sort of besides
the point
um and i'll i'll dive into that so
broadly speaking
critical race theory is a legal
framework
for looking at how our current systems
interact with race
you could say like a legal framework for
looking at systemic racism and
it's been taught it's academic it's been
taught in law schools for decades
and it's high level academics as in like
you know
for older people and and that is
important that becomes kind of very
central in the democratic narrative that
exists right now
so let's start where everyone seems to
agree
which is that all this talk about
critical race theory in the mainstream
seems to stem back to this one guy chris
rufo
who's a conservative journalist
documentarian
who last year
became familiar with these anti-racism
trainings that were happening
within different federal agencies that
were saying things like
you know meritocracy itself is white
supremacist and
values like individualism as white
supremacists you know and then
you know and then a whole bunch of other
things right around systemic racism and
privilege etc
and chris ruffo the narrative seems to
go
according to both sides is outraged by
what he's seeing here he goes on fox
news quite famously
and is on tucker carlson's show and
demands that president trump
uh ban critical race theory as part of
trainings for federal employees so trump
does that biden comes into office
and reverses trump's ban on critical
race theory
and that's when the fight really moves
to the schools and that's when
chris ruffo starts working with
republicans around the country to
write legislation banning critical race
theory
in schools in curriculums around the
country and
here's what's interesting so the
reaction that democrats
seem to have had to this whole thing
has been to take this line of
it's stupid to call this even critical
race theory this isn't
critical race theory critical race
theory is this high
you know level academic thing that
is taught in law schools obviously we're
not teaching that to elementary school
students
and like that's true but also to me
feels like it's very much missing the
point because it's not
like the point here is about the
curriculum and what we're teaching and
so
being like nana you're you've made this
intentional effort to make everything
bad
critical race theory it feels besides
the point to me but that seems to be
what's being hammered
[Music]
today's episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by our
sponsor better help guys i cannot
emphasize this enough
take care of your mental health i
started doing it myself
and better help has literally changed my
life and changed how i
operate on a daily basis so what is it
it is a private secure
way to talk to professional counseling
securely online
um so you can send a message to your
counselor any time you get paired with
someone
up to 48 hours you start chatting and
you don't have to sit in the
uncomfortable waiting room it's all
online it's all personal and private and
you can talk about
whether you've got depression or stress
anxiety relationships sleeping
lgbtq matters grief self-esteem you name
it for me it's just about
staying focused pulling off some steam
and talking about all the things that
are on my mind during the week
so i want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
ten percent off your first month by
listening to our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang join over one million people have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help help
[Music]
critical race theory was essentially
written by
two individuals in the 90s a couple
decades ago
derek bell and kimberly crenshaw in that
document if you're a republican
reading it um i don't think you would
agree
you would disagree as strongly as they
are right now if you actually read what
they wrote because they also
they talk about systemic racism on
things they also talk about
um material interest and structural
poverty
and um things that a lot of
a lot of us can agree upon like hey a
lot of our schools are not funded very
well like period
yeah right like there's things that they
are talking about that is bigger than
basically they're saying hey
we should be concerned with the material
well-being
of minorities and the way in which our
legal systems keep minorities from from
material well-being
rather than linguistic debates
right like if the point i think
summarized is like if we get every white
person
to stop ever saying or singing the
n-word or whatever
you're still going to have the wealth
gap and so like what really have we
accomplished
and i think there's you know that that
goes to i think something that speaks
that you and i agree with in terms of
not that we think people should be
saying the n-word but that
like a universal basic income is such a
more powerful tool than
so many of the other debates we end up
having in the quote unquote discourse
um because they even talk about
ncrt they actually get to talking about
solutions and policies as opposed to
just rhetoric
and that so it's it's the whole thing to
me is ironic we're like
we're debating or how terrible crt is
but no one's ever actually read
what they are and therefore we're not
actually debating critical race theory
we're debating
at its core what's getting taught to
children and then what we're allowed to
talk about
and we should say this critical race
theory is a is
a body of scholarship so there's not one
thing this is why you actually can't
define it
because zach you're right that
in some of the early days in the early
iterations of critical race theory
that's what was being discussed but it
it you've had other scholars weigh in
and other scholars focus on other things
and also that's true
it's a body do that under the umbrella
of critical race theory so this is why
you really can't get to a definition of
what this
is because it's a body of scholarship
with people saying a whole bunch of
different things about what it is so my
hopes of making this simple for
everybody
have been dashed and i think that's okay
because i think it doesn't
matter yes it doesn't matter okay keep
going okay so you have
a big blow-up that happens in loudoun
county in pennsylvania and this is what
you're hearing a lot about and if you're
seeing
um clips of parents like screaming and
being like
on either side of this but being like
how dare you teach my kid that because
they're black they're always
oppressed and because they're white
they're out they're inherently racist
that's probably from this loudoun county
school
board meeting or meet series of meetings
that have happened
because of some proposed changes to the
loudoun county curriculum
so the daily covers this as part of
their coverage
in general the daily podcast covers this
as part of their general coverage on
like what is critical race theory and
what i found so striking was they keep
it
the whole episode kept it sort of very
high level and they didn't at
any point get into the specifics of what
the proposed curriculum was is in
loudoun county which
feels to me like what we actually should
be talking about
not like what is the definition of
critical race theory so i want to just
the conclusion that is formed
in this daily episode is that basically
the fight over critical race theory
is a fight between two camps the first
camp
that's call it in favor of critical race
theory though those are the same people
who are being like this isn't actually
critical race theory
republicans are creating a straw man
boogeyman to attack and it's
not even what this is like they're so
stupid right that same camp
um are the people who are willing to
admit that systemic racism exists and
that it's something we need to tackle
and something we need to teach our kids
and that for too long our education
system has completely
has treated racism like it's something
in the past and we need to fix that et
cetera et cetera
so the daily is saying that's the people
who are in one camp of this and the
people on the other camp of this
are and the way they do it it feels very
much like are the people who are
unwilling to acknowledge systemic racism
and are unwilling to grapple with
the idea that america isn't the perfect
bastion of meritocracy that they
once thought and that they themselves
may be a part of a problem
they really paint it like people who are
kind of unwilling to face
and the feeling you get is like the
reality about america
and i can give you the exact quote yeah
can you give the quote is michael
barbara who's the host of the daily
says so at its core this is about
and that this is the fight over critical
race theory
so at its core this is about whether a
large group of americans mostly white
but not all white
can or should accept the idea that
racism is not merely historical
not simply a relic but something very
present and systemic and something they
need to take responsibility for
and then the guest responds yes that's
right so they've summarized this as
being this is a fight about whether or
not people will take responsibility for
systemic racism what is frustrating to
me when you hear that
is that i'm of the camp
where and i think a lot about i would
argue that the majority of americans are
in this camp
where like systemic racism exists we
have structural problems in this country
um that are advantaging certain races
arranging white races over over black
race like you go down the list
at the same time you can still think
that teaching a child that competition
in meritocracy
is inherently racist um is a bad thing i
think those are the things that made
america
fantastic um and
yeah i agree daley's arguing that we
can't talk about it without
like if i take the other side of that
that i'm racist
i'm acknowledging there's no systemic
racism this is the needle that needs to
be thread
right and this is the help of the
conversation
isn't being said you have and this is
what i'll end up repeating this over and
over again i feel like as we have these
conversations because i think it's what
you see
very consistently which is you have
rep you have democrats focusing on a a
macro narrative
you have them saying systemic racism
exists
we should be teaching this and then you
have republicans focusing
on a micro narrative which is okay well
third graders in cupertino
were asked to rank themselves and their
classmates according to their privilege
which you know it just means according
to like race features which is
bizarre and reductive and doesn't take
into account all sorts of other
dynamics and a fan like all these other
things that can make somebody privileged
or not and it's also just a really weird
way to start training third graders to
think to think in my opinion
and as somebody who very much believes
in systemic racism so you have
republicans focusing on these like micro
examples of things in curriculum that
feel to a lot of us
as being quite off and and so you have
these two groups talking past each other
because we're not arguing about the same
things
and and it's so frustrating to me that
the new york the new york times in this
daily episode and i take the new york
times because again they're held up as
still like the gold standard of
journalism in a lot of camps
so you know you know you're getting that
narrative or worse in the other
you know mainstream media channels right
like the new york times was taking
the stupidest of the rights arguments
and debunking those in this podcast
instead of taking
frankly the most legitimate of the
rights arguments and debunking those and
this is what you see over and over and
over again
which is so freaking frustrating so i
would say like the needle to thread here
is is to me there's a lot
yes systemic racism exists clearly there
are all sorts of systems and you can
i could talk to you about them there's
this there's a whatever we don't have to
get into that if somebody
doubts this feel free to dm me and i can
um
right there there are legal systems that
have existed and frankly continue to
exist that very much
clearly disadvantage like black people
other races
other than white people at the same time
to treat it like you are racist
because or like you don't believe in
systemic racism
because you do have problems with some
of the specific things being taught in
these anti-racism trainings
and and have a problem with everything
being reduced to
power according to race which which is
absolutely happening
um it's it's ridiculous i mean we have
kimberly crenshaw who mentioned earlier
as somebody who was a founder of crt she
coined the term critical race theory
and she gave a muted response to be fair
but then the new yorker interviewed her
and and asked her about some of these
anti-racism trainings and she was like
you know i see some of these and i think
huh that's not exactly how i would do it
right like she's even you know expressed
hesitations around some of these
specific trainings
and i think to kind of round this out
like
and again this is probably something
i'll say over and over again
my biggest problem with democrats
call it considering myself one of them
and
this trickles then into media narratives
is that democrats judge policies
based on their intentions rather than
their results
and then if you criticize the results
they treat you like you are a critic of
the intention
so if i say hey i think we should fight
systemic racism i think we should teach
about systemic racism
even to kids though not in math and
science classes which is a whole other
thing you know
there's this in some of these school
districts you have
the idea that things about structural
racism need to be taught in every
academic discipline so math and science
classes are teaching you about systemic
racism which feels sort of not the point
so if you criticize some of the specific
results coming out of these curriculums
or saying that
i don't think this is even actually
going to help fight systemic racism they
will tell you
you don't believe systemic racism exists
and that is so
frustrating um so we have to have a
conversation that both acknowledges
systemic racism
and has a healthy debate about the the
specifics in certain curriculums
and that is the point that is why we
have two peop two white people talking
about race right now because we
have to talk about you know if you don't
talk about this it just bottles up and
it's shitty
and i felt you feel it all the time
don't talk about this you just get
people
who get so ingrained in their own
narrative that they don't realize
that the other side is fighting
something completely different that
you're like you're not even you're
you're not arguing on the same plane
we're not arguing about the same things
we're having totally different
conversations
and it's so frustrating it's why a lot
of things don't get done because we're
not even
like on the climate climate change for
example like we're still debating its
existence and severity instead of
solving the actual problem and
literally what's so fascinating about
critical race theory is that kimberly
crenshaw one of the
like literally coined the term and
invented this essentially
said i'm gonna give you her quote
because i think it's worthwhile and it's
never
talked about very often i'm gonna read
the full quotes like three sentences she
said
a persistent internal critique accuses
the movement of straying from its
materialist roots so she talks about
material interests and resources like
universe-based income and things like
that
straying from its materialist roots and
dwelling overly on matters of concern to
middle-class minorities
hyphen microaggressions racial insults
unconscious discrimination and
affirmative action in higher education
if racial oppression has material and
cultural roots
attacking only its ideational and
linguistic
expression is apt to do little for the
underlying structures of inequality much
less the plight of the deeply poor
simply put if we talk about
the semantics and the words and the
verbiage
it's all at this middle class level and
maybe on the margins we're doing some
good things but it doesn't change
any of the fundamentals and it's why you
and i were always attracted to universal
basic income i would challenge all of
you listening this to
feel confident knowing that this
debate over critical race theory and
carl make sure i understand you right
is not an actual debate over critical
race theory there's critical race theory
and then what we're being
taught in schools and they are
converging in a weird way
both through our mainstream press and
through these conversations here's how i
would summarize it i would say
there's a debate to be had over what
critical race theory is and
is it being taught in our schools
republicans would say
yes ibram kendy and rob and deangelo
are all derivatives of critical race
theor the original critical race theory
and
and these curriculums are derivatives of
them so therefore it's critical race
theory the left would say
no critical race series an academic
structure taught in law schools blah
blah
that to me almost doesn't matter who
really gives an f if this is critical
race theory or not
right but the democrats feel like
they're kind of trying to make the
argument about
that but as a way to discredit
republicans right like they're saying
republicans are so stupid they think
this is critical race theory and it's
not
so that's a big part of the democratic
narrative and it's like honestly it
doesn't
effing matter they just pick another
term then and then there's a second
debate
that is the debate that is in my opinion
not being had as much
which is what should these curriculums
look like
and the right has just smeared them
wholesale which is ridiculous
and so you have they've successfully
used their term critical race theory to
fear monger about teaching kids about
systemic racism and that's
wrong and but then the left won't
actually engage with
or acknowledge hey some of this stuff
that is being taught does feel like it's
frankly counterproductive
like it makes everything about race to a
nine-year-old
in a way that may or may not really be
beneficial
and the left won't really engage with
any of those micro specifics about
what's being taught when they talk about
it it's very broad level we're just
teaching about systemic racism
so those are the two debates what is
critical race theory is that what's
being taught in schools
my answer to that is who gives a [ __ ]
and then what are we teaching
kids in schools and what is the
curriculum here and this is the
conversation that
we should all be looking for more often
and and tracking much more closely
and by the way we should not be banning
critical race theory
like as a big proponent of call it free
speech and somebody who's critical of
the democrats on that front
republicans effort to like ban what they
are considering critical race theory
is is absolutely alarming to me and
just goes to show we've like lost all
ideological core to these parties the
fact that republicans who are like
anti-big government anti-government
involvement etc etc
now want the government to get involved
to silence what they don't like
is like just just peak hypocrisy and
absurdity in my opinion
i'm with you that usually banning
anything
um tends to not be great for free speech
and
um tends to be difficult to enforce and
actually has a counter effect and the
people more interested in what you're
trying to ban
um um i would say this
i think the good news is for those of
you listening who maybe have kids it
does appear
that our local representatives are still
very very reactive to their constituents
i felt that when i was running for
president running for mayor i do think
like
when they get calls and complaints they
are um they feel that they have to be
responsive um
so i do think that the fact that there
are wars
in these local communities is probably
ignore the mainstream narrative i
imagine this is a good thing to be
talking about and that's where they get
settled
um but i i don't know
i don't love the concept of teaching a
child that being competitive
is a form of racist white privilege or
or hateful and i think most people
actually agree with that and the and
again the problem is that you have
republicans painting it like that's all
these curriculums are which
from what i can see is not true at all
and democrats ignoring that
any part of the curriculum is that which
is also not true
um and you know for example i mean
because again i'm not
i'm not trying to make this seem like
it's just the democrats who are are the
problem here which
like like loud and county there was a
narrative that they were like
banning advanced math courses for the
sake of equity
which was a that's not happening loudoun
county was
was changing the was changing their math
curriculum structure
in a variety of ways but that got
misconstrued as
they're banning advanced math but that
was
not actually the case um and it became
this very popular narrative
got it so kyle let me ask you this i'll
give it a wrap this conversation
um how does this play out are we going
to see
um different schools adopt various
versions of crt
is this going to die when the next new
polarizing issue comes up what do you
think happens
well again democrats will yell at you if
you say schools are adopting crt
because they according to democrats
they're not about whatever and i'm
inclined to
agree with that so this is why i get
like so you know
i actually i like the term john
mcwhorter who everyone should check out
is a a black thinker scholar i don't
know
what his actual technical does he teach
a job title
i don't think i don't know what porter
does anyways he's turned coined to term
i believe he coined it
um he calls it third wave anti-racism
sorry
john mcguire teaches at colombia great
um that's a a plus for colombia so john
mcwhorter has coined this term
third wave anti-racism and i think you
know
it's like great maybe we should just
call all of this that like
third wave anti-racism curriculums um
so yeah i absolutely go i think you're
going to see this
you're going to see a continuation of
exactly what you're seeing right now
which is you have
southern and midwestern states um
banning it and to the extent that it's
not banned
it is treated as so toxic that you don't
see it being taught and then you have
northern and coastal states uh
very much continuing to and especially
elite schools continuing to include
third wave anti-racism ideas into their
curriculums
um and i think the ideal blend is that
you
you kind of teach that there are a
variety of opinions on things like right
like when you're teaching american
history one of the debates has been
do you teach the 1619 version which is
this
you know the controversial new york
times piece about
1619 project or do you teach the 1776
version which is you know we started in
1776
and i think heck like teach teach that
there's disagreements around it and
kind of show both sides and let students
learn to think critically and make up
their own minds about it
unfortunately i don't think that's where
we're gonna land as often i don't think
we're gonna land with uh
as often with um kind of let's teach
let's teach all of it because
both sides are treating the other side's
perspective
as though it it is an existential threat
republicans are saying you know america
is existentially threatened
by this critical race theory stuff
and democrats are saying america is
existently threatened by not grappling
with our racist roots
and we are going to just continue to
perpetuate racism so long as we don't
singularly ascribe to this third wave
anti-racism ideology
i do think that's kind of where we're
trending where you're gonna
start to see like very different maybe
even
at times fundamentally different
education systems
um depending where you are in the
country that's where i believe this is
going you need to teach
students to think critically and that's
the biggest thing is to
to create independent-minded youths
and what i'm challenging all of us to
listen on this podcast
and we're gonna do our best we're gonna
work our ass off to help you tune
back in so when these do come up in your
lives your community
at the kitchen table you're talking your
kid you were able to articulate
your critical response carly riley thank
you for being smarter than me
and most no offense to me listening
probably martin most people listening
i'm
always fascinated by the way you can
articulate these things from both sides
of
um frankly the political spectrum this
has been your thursday update on yang
speaks
thank you all for joining follow us on
twitter at zac
rauman or carly p riley nailed it
yeah we're there i'm actually zach
underscore groman i think zach roman was
taken by me in middle school and i don't
know how to unlock it
oh that's funny disaster um yeah
anyway i'm on instagram too i'm trying
to like instagram promote these things
you know used to post i'm also carly p
riley on instagram we love you guys
thanks for tuning in take care
you